[Musica]
l'anno scorso 11 febbraio del 2016
la scienza annuncia abbiamo misurato le
onde gravitazionali le onde
gravitazionali sono state per la prima
volta ipotizzate da albert einstein e
nel 1916 cioè cento anni prima ma
nessuno l'aveva mai appunto misurate e
l'abbiamo fatto recentemente grazie alla
misurazione appunto delle onde arrivati
sulla terra dallo scontro tra due buchi
neri è avvenuto un miliardo e 300
milioni di anni fa
i protagonisti di questa incredibile
avventura scientifica che si intravedono
piuttosto bene nello schermo sono due
strumenti fantastici i gemelli league
sono due interferometri sono negli stati
uniti un e louisiana l'altro nello stato
di washington si tratta praticamente di
due tunnel messi ad angolo retto quindi
delle l enormi con un abbraccio di 4
chilometri un raggio laser viene il
separato in due raggi identici
all'incrocio dei due tunnel sparato
lungo i bracci questi tornano indietro
questi due laser vengono confrontati se
la terra subisce uno scossone
gravitazionale perché passa un'onda e la
terra e anche noi ovviamente queste due
bracci in qualche modo si muovono i
raggi che si rincontrano al centro sono
sposati
se tornano uguali non de gravitazionali
se tornano sfasati si onde
gravitazionali
ecco attraverso un grafico si veda
questo per la prima volta abbiamo
misurato l'esistenza di queste onde
ipotizzate cento anni prima
cento anni prima perché perché ci
abbiamo messo così tanto a scoprire una
cosa così pazzesca perché delle quattro
forze fondamentali che godrebbe un
universo della gravità sia per abbiamo
veramente poco mentre manipoliamo senza
problemi la forza elettromagnetica e le
due forze nucleari la forza forte della
forza debole e le nostre conoscenze
sulla gravità non sono andate molto
oltre
a questa leggendaria mela che cade sulla
testa di newton perché è una domanda
strana perché sappiamo così poco della
gravità
un po perché la percepiamo in qualsiasi
momento cioè ci sentiamo pesanti siamo
attratti dalla terra
un po perché è molto debole perché in
fondo basta un minimo sforzo per averne
ragione e vincerla e un po perché
sentite un po forse è l'unica forza tra
le quattro ad avere una natura multi
dimensionale significa che va oltre le
tre dimensioni spaziali più una
temporale che noi viviamo
quotidianamente perché per esempio per
la teoria delle stringhe che attualmente
è la reginetta tra le teorie come
aspirante al titolo di teoria del tutto
cioè la tv che spiega un po come
funziona l'universo se la gravità è così
debole così diffusa e perché va oltre
appunto alla natura multi dimensionale
scioccati significa che ci sono altri
dimensioni
al di là di quelle che noi percepiamo
quanti dimensione o 11 secondo la teoria
dello stile le stringhe 40 secondo altre
resta il fatto che probabilmente ci sono
e sono dappertutto anche mentre noi
camminiamo anche dietro la libreria dove
galleggia matthew mcconaughey in
interstellar una sequenza fantastica che
forse gli ha di fatto vincere fatto
vincere questo film il premio oscar per
gli effetti speciali
ok vediamo come funziona la gravità
immaginiamo di prendere un telo elastico
lo attendiamo per bene li mettiamo in
mezzo un peso questo peso in curva lo
spazio tempo cioè il tessuto spazio
temporale viene incurvato qual sia
soggetto si vede un po gli passa accanto
ne viene attratto o meglio non è che lì
viene attratto ci cada addosso noi in
questo momento stiamo cadendo verso il
centro della terra
la luna in questo momento cade verso il
centro della terra e noi verso il suo
centro
ok per che però noi che abbiamo una
massa e che includiamo lo spazio tempo
lo stiamo facendo in questo momento non
abbiamo oggetti appiccicati addosso
perché lì attraiamo o meglio perché ci
cadono addosso a chi sei e piccini
perché la forza di gravità si manifesta
nel momento in cui ad agire sono i
giganti pianeta e stelle o addirittura i
buchi neri che abbiamo visto prima
questo ragazzo si chiama carla gb
hartfield fisico tedesco non ringiovanì
simo sul fronte belga parti come
volontario proprio mentre scriveva ad
einstein le sue prime supposizioni sul
buco nero e einstein non è detto che
all'inizio lo prese molto seriamente
resto ha fatto che lui fu il primo ad
ipotizzarlo mentre il primo buco nero
della storia del cinema è questo qui non
so se vi ricordate questo film
diversamente giovani forse sì
the black hole è stata la risposta della
disney renda peraltro a guerre stellari
che all'epoca erano stavano spopolando
la disney tira fuori questo orrendo fin
dove i buoni attraversano un buco nero
per sfuggire i cattivissimi andare da
un'altra parte dell'universo un buco
nero e questa è la sua rappresentazione
diciamo artisticamente più realistica
cioè teoricamente dovremmo vederlo o
dovremmo intravederlo così come lo stato
intervenendo voi è qualcosa che tutti
tutt'altro che vuoto cioè non è
attraversabile anzi e densissimo è
talmente pieno di materie da incurvare
appunto quel famoso spazio tempo fino a
un puntino infinitesimale con una
densità infinita con una pira dita
infinita tale per cui neanche la luce
riesce a sfuggire la luce va a 300.000
chilometri al secondo
è la cosa più veloce dell'universo di
più non si può ed è per questo che
appare nero proprio perché la luce non
sfugge ce ne parla in modo stupendo
stephen hawking che è uno dei principali
studiosi dei buchi neri qui
rappresentato in questo film stupendo lo
avete visto da tiri a del tutto da di
redman e il quale appunto è stato uno
dei primi adesso sta tornando indietro
su alcune posizioni ma è stato uno dei
primi a studiarli seriamente ok ma se
non universo nulla si crea e nulla si
distrugge tutto ciò che finisce dentro
un buco nero forse da qualche parte deve
finire e dove finisce
lo stesso einstein ipotizzò l'esistenza
di passaggi multidimensionali o che
connettono diverse regioni dello spazio
detti i ponti di einstein rosen che
funzionano proprio così guardate c'è un
punto d'ingresso c'è un punto di uscita
su spazi tempo perfettamente ripiegati
per farla breve ci vogliono 8 ore per
avere da milano in treno fino a potenza
ci avrei potuto mettere un saltino se
imparasse a curvare lo spazio tempo e
facessi coincidere milano con potenza
ecco uscendo proprio dal tinello di casa
io avrei tranquillamente nel suo piede
beh noi ancora ci si arriva e magari
speriamo ho azzeccato tutto a installa
gaza che anche questo sulla sui wormhole
c'è appunto i buchi guardate un po
torniamo alla mela i buchi di verme il
wormhole che appunto sono la grande
speranza per i viaggi interplanetari
perché altrimenti sarebbe un bel dramma
effettuarli nella scienza ancora non
esistono ma esistono eccome nella
fantascienza qui vediamo ancora la
sequenza di interstellar quando i due
protagonisti matthew mcconaughey è la
bellissima anne hathway
si fanno sparare da un buco nero per
raggiungere la velocità simili a quella
della luce
serve impossibile si sarebbero sciolti
in bottiglia subatomica peccato non
tanto per lui quanto per lei invece per
fortuna non hanno fatto questa cosa
oppure questo è un altro ruolo
cinematografico importante stargate
in questo caso il passaggio si apre
attraverso un manufatto una specie di
anello né magico che connette il nostro
mondo al fanta egitto di questi questi
specie di appunto egiziani alieni un
altro wormhole questo è un po più
interessante dal punto di vista
scientifico perché è quello aperto nel
film contact fincon tac non è una roba
stupidissima perché fu la versione
cinematografica dell'omonimo romanzo di
karas aggancia un astrofisico importante
del secolo scorso
qui vediamo la povera jodie foster che
viene buttata nel warm hall e dopo un
viaggio importante finisce da qualche
parte nell'universo o addirittura da
qualche parte dentro jodie foster
insomma un pò un casino
però il fatto è che questa sequenza
ricorda in modo diciamo appena appena
accennato a quest'altra un po più famosa
non voglio dire che zemeckis ha copiato
diciamo che se profondamente ispirato
siano 2001 odissea nello spazio
chiaramente torniamo alla scienza
questa è la rappresentazione artistica
di una superficie di un pianeta vicino
proxima b e il pianeta in questo momento
che abbiamo scoperto più vicino alla
terra che ruota intorno a prossima
centauri una stellina una nana rossa
nella costellazione del centauro sta
dall'altra parte non la vediamo da qui a
breve lo faccio vedere perché è vista da
qui poco più di quattro anni luce
significa che in questo momento se un
alieno abitante su questo pianeta ci
guarda se ci vedrebbe come eravamo
quattro anni fa come eravamo che
facevamo non lo so ma loro ci vedrebbero
in quelle questa giornata la vedrebbero
cioè quattro anni ok questo oggetto qui
questo puntino che vedete sfrecciare è a
tutt'oggi il veicolo più veloce eccolo
qui costruito dall'uomo si chiama new
horizon ed è il satellite che ha
raggiunto due anni fa
l'orbita di plutone vi ricordate quelle
immagini bellissime del pianeta col
cuore e quelle plutone ok eccolo qui non
rise onna è molto veloce va a 16 circa
chilometri al secondo
non è poco se dovessimo mandare in your
eyes on su proxima b impiegherebbe 75
mila anni circa ma tanto bene
se non riusciamo ad aprire un wormhole
anche l'oggetto più veloce che abbiamo
costruito fino adesso ci mette 75 milani
vi ricordo che dinosauri si sono estinti
65 mila anni fa
insomma l'ordine di tempo è quella vabbè
allora vediamo se c'è qualcos'altro
dal punto di vista tecnologico cioè
eccolo qui si chiama black stars choc ed
è un progetto attualmente finanziato da
un magnate russo che a yuri miller ha
dietro l'avallo scientifico di stephen
hopkins è anche il nostro amico
zuckerberg che in questo momento si sta
guardando se lo diano in cosa consiste
si tratta di micro onde grosse come una
mela punto ecco che ritorna con delle
vele molto leggere sparate nello spazio
da queste capsule e spinte ma dei laser
potentissimi che partono tutti insieme
dalla terra gonfiano con i fotoni questi
vele e sperano l'oggettivo ha più o meno
un quinto della velocità della luce
significa che la sordina riderebbe su
proxima di più o meno in vent'anni
quindi vent'anni per arrivare 4 anni per
ricevere segnale di ritorno anche a una
velocità prossimo di un quinto di quella
della luce
ci impiegherebbe sul pianeta più vicino
24 anni per avere il primo segnale è poi
un botta risposta tano e la sonda di 4
anni per volta po scomodo anche chattare
con la sponda ogni quattro anni
bisogna ricordarsi almeno cosa s'è detto
ok rimandiamo alla fantascienza perché
se quel progetto di prima è qualcosa di
scientifico simile alla fantascienza ma
è la fantascienza è stata tradotta in
modo così scientificamente corretto come
in star trek tanto da guadagnarsi questa
serie
un volume che proprio la fisica di star
trek che spiega come funziona
l'enterprise che vediamo qua nella
versione vecchia e nuova
come funziona interprise questo è il mio
interprise personale
in pratica il famoso motore a curvatura
non fa altro che creare una depressione
spazio temporale davanti alla
l'astronave e una compressione spazio
temporale dietro quindi si fosse un
enorme onda gravitazionale che
l'enterprise scavalca come una sorta di
surf meno chiaro è invece come funziona
il millennium falco di guerre stellari
perché se è vero che va velocissimo non
sappiamo però quanto vada veloce o
quantomeno non ci dicono perché va bene
vi saluto questa me la mangio dopo
[Applauso]